hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the last vlog v-log or
whatever you want to call it I've been
doing this for almost two years I still
don't know what to call it but vlog of
Cincinnati and this is weird because
we've kind of come full circle
considering that this is the first room
I started recording videos to an
audience of one only like my friend was
my subscriber who I just said goodbye to
yesterday and that was really sad I've
been saying goodbye to a lot of friends
before I go out to LA and some sad some
happy some indifferent towards my
location but it's just been an
interesting experience because I've
never moved I've never moved out of
Cincinnati I've never been gone from
this location so it's it's interesting
and I have to say again what I say at
all these videos is just thank you guys
so much for believing in me and
launching this channel from nothingness
to something incredible where you guys
are able to do incredible things and I
do have the final numbers for the
charity shirts that were donated or the
charity donation of the chick vo that
charity thing that we did last week it
was the most fun I've ever had I've been
trying to upload it all week long it's
technically on YouTube you can find a
link in the description but it's still
processing so it doesn't show up in the
video list either way it's there thank
you guys so much for making it one of
the best live streams probably the best
live stream we've ever done so thank you
guys even though it's a total train
wreck in terms of me were operating it
but that's so anyway I have the final
numbers um the little disclaimer I wish
that more of the money it cost to make
the shirts would have gone towards the
charity the problem was these were like
more design more colors more intricate
shirts so they cost more to print
because there were three separate shirts
they you know you couldn't get the big
deals for getting like high volume as it
normally would because the vault the
bundle had a $10 discount that $10 plied
away from the donation that would have
come to charity it didn't apply away
from the reduction cost it just applied
to the profits but either way all that
said you still raised an ass
anomaly huge amount of money fifty-eight
thousand eight hundred and ten dollars
and 56 cents that's more than any
charity we phrased in the past that
that's just that and you guys
contributed straight to the website an
amount of fourteen thousand seventeen
dollars and seventy two cents
totaling 72 thousand eight hundred and
twenty eight dollars and twenty eight
cents which is by far more than we've
ever raised in the past all the child's
place so thank you guys so much for
doing that now as you may know our goal
was eighty thousand dollars so we ended
up about seventy 1771 no 7171 dollars
and seventy tunes these repeating
numbers were getting to me so to make up
that amount I donated a thousand dollars
during the charity but to make up this
amount to make sure that we go over the
donation I contributed another nine
thousand dollars when I made the
transfer to the bank I had actually set
up a wire transfer straight to it so
that raises our total to eighty one
thousand eight hundred and twenty-eight
dollars in twenty eight cents almost
eight to eight to eight to eight but a
thousand dollars off from that but
either way that pushes us over and that
makes this the highest amount raised
we've ever done a total of eighty one
thousand eight hundred and twenty eight
dollars and twenty eight cents you guys
will probably be able to see that pretty
soon depending on when that goes through
the link to the charity page is in the
description you can see the total raised
there hopefully I think you can but it
should reflect that in just in your
future now considering that I I donated
a lot this time mostly because it was my
last livestream and I wanted to make it
very special and also you know it's no
secret we've been growing astronomically
quickly the the success of the channel
is just immense it's more than I ever
could imagined
and in some ways I feel like it's more
than I deserve I definitely have been
making a living from this and I've been
getting a lot of money and I've never
been one that really wants things I I
don't care about like cars I don't care
about cool toys except for computers I
love computers but you know the things
that keep me going are cheap I feel like
the Joker right now I have cheap tastes
but but either way um I make a lot of
money on YouTube that's probably no
secret so I want to make sure that that
money goes towards the right cause and
I've always thought that I need to lead
by example and I want to put the
majority of what I make towards these
charity efforts whether it's through a
donation myself or organizing my time or
just using this fan base for good and I
want people that know that I believe in
that message 100% and I want to continue
believing in that and I want to make
sure that you guys put your trust in the
right place and hopefully that place is
in me so thank you guys so much for
everything that you have done up to this
point it's it's it's it's incredible
because God being in this room it was
weird I haven't slept in this bed in
almost a year and it felt like I slept
there a lifetime ago you know that's how
long this year has been for me waking up
every single day thinking about the
channel and thinking about better ways
to improve what I do and myself and
making the videos better and like making
myself better and just going every
single day thinking about that it makes
time go at a snail's pace time crawled
by for me and that's not a bad thing
because it's just been
pushing a boulder up a hill every day I
look at every single thing I can not a
single second of my day isn't spent
thinking about this channel and how I
can improve and it's been such a
rewarding exhausting journey but it's
not over yet because when I get to LA
there's gonna be so much more cool stuff
I can't wait to show you guys what the
things that I have in store when I get
to LA and it's just two days away I'm
leaving tomorrow and I'll probably set
up on Wednesday but it's gonna be
amazing and all the new subscribers that
have joined and there's been so many of
you in the recent weasal it was like we
hit 1.5 million then like two weeks
later we have 1.6 million then we can
half later we're at 1.7 and now we're
almost you know halfway to 1.8 it's
incredible I think we got something
around 13 or 14 thousand subs just
yesterday I can't even wrap my head
around that I was amazed when I got like
10 well ago blast I was in this room a
hundred was amazing to me in a day and
I'm so grateful that you guys believed
in me and that's why it's so important
to me that I make sure that Trust is
well-placed so if you're new to the
channel check out these videos I'm gonna
put annotations here here links in the
description this broad be to my 10,000
subscriber vlog so that you can see who
I was and hopefully it's not too much
different than Who I am now back when I
had 10,000 subs which was completely
amazing at the time too and here's my
draw my life and I don't know what I'm
gonna put down there but I'll try to
find something if there's nothing there
then just don't look down there so
anyway just my hands thank you guys so
much for everything that you've done I
I'm so proud of what we've built and
what we've managed and what we've
accomplished I was so proud so sincerely
from the bottom of my heart thank you
guys so much for believing me Thank You
Cincinnati for having me thank you all
my friends who have believed in me not
believed in me just made fun of me I
don't care
thank you guys and thank you and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]